[Music]  sex is healthy people don't shame it  embrace it Scott Eastwood dishing on his  love life on the latest episode of his  live life better podcast the Pacific Rim  uprising star gets candid with his guest  Emily Morse doctor of human sexuality  about all things sex dating and  relationships and Scott has no problem  opening up about his past rendevouz I  remember in an early on relationships  you know in my when I was in my early  early 20s  there was you you you know I felt more  sexually advanced than some of the  people I was with right I had been down  a darker road connection haven't found  it yet as for whether the actor is still  off the market he did not pull back I'm  single single dating okay yeah are you  having sex done I am having sex lots of  it with one person or several people you  know it depends on when you ask me  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]